good afternoon and uh thank you thank
you very much uh for coming I'm Richard
PR uh uh in ecology and evolutionary
biology and the director of the Frankie
program in science and Humanities uh
thanks for coming uh I see today's
speaker has attracted lots of new faces
so uh welcome to uh today um just a we
uh April is extraordinarily busy for all
of us here at University but uh just to
let you know we have a few exciting
things coming up uh many of them are uh
uh collaborative Ventures uh with
environmental Humanities uh forestry
school and elsewhere so for example on
tomorrow Tuesday the 18th at noon uh
we're co-hosting uh a uh second of the
environmental Humanities talks uh on the
the papal and cyclical care of our
common home um then on uh Thursday to
Saturday uh April 20th to 22nd uh there
is the editing nature Summit uh uh a
organized by the Yale Institute for
biospheric studies and and ourselves uh
then on Saturday April 22nd there's New
Perspectives in environmental history a
conference uh being held all day um and
then um the last uh Schulman lecture in
science and the humanities mindful Minds
different brains historical Reflections
on America's love affair with meditation
that's on Wednesday April 26th at 5: PM
uh and then and then lastly a a
Shameless plug of my own uh I have a
book party coming up on May 8th my own
book on the evolution of beauty uh What
uh uh so uh there is actually some
Humanities content there as well okay
that made for Theo so it's a pleasure to
introduce uh today's speaker Hof chain
he is the the hans's rousing professor
of uh history and philosophy of science
at the University of Cambridge educated
at uh Caltech and uh and at Stanford uh
his interest include the history of
philosophy uh history and philosophy of
chemistry and physics from the 18th
century onward uh he has uh uh most
recently served as the vice president
for the British Society for history of
science uh and um uh his uh 2004 book I
think based on his dissertation was
inventing temperature measurement and
scientific progress and most recently
he's the author of is water H2O evidence
pluralism and realism so uh uh it was
through his book on isw water H2O uh
that a colleague of mine and I read in a
biology seminar graduate seminar some
years ago uh and it's taken a number of
years with hass's busy schedule but I'm
really really pleased to uh uh finally
be able to host him here at Yale and
today he will speaking on is there room
for pluralism in science please join me
and welcome you
[Applause]
H thank you very much for that kind
introduction Professor PR and I also
want to thank Professor Vagner um
somewhere in there yes uh for inviting
me to Yale I want to thank Tai camp for
organizing my whole trip so nicely and
of course um I'm told Mr Frankie is here
thank you very much for making this
whole thing possible it is actually my
first time speaking at Yale so it's a
great pleasure and honor and I'm
especially pleased to be speaking in the
Frankie program as
the joining of the science and the
humanities is really one of the main
concerns of my own academic
life
now what I want to present to you today
is an argument for pluralism in science
before I say anything is the volume okay
is everybody hearing
good now to put it very briefly what I
mean by pluralism is a commitment to
maintain multiple systems of knowledge
in each field of
inquiry even if they disagree with each
other in some important ways for a very
exam brief example consider the long
running competition between the wave
theory of light and the particle theory
of light insights and results from each
of them feeding productively into much
later developments that we now have in
the form of quantum mechanics couldn't
have had it without both wave theory and
particle theory having developed as they
did so the basic pluralist intuition is
that the progress of science is actually
helped by having multiple theories and
multiple methodologies even within one
field of science each approach would
make its own distinct contributions to
knowledge and the different approaches
can also interact productively with each
other science has often benefited from
such plurality and you would be helped
by having more of it now this is a
deliberately controversial
position and today's talk I decided
should be a rhetorical exercise designed
to destabilize some existing intuitions
and plant hopefully some fresh thoughts
in your head by means of some
imaginative arguments and memorable
examples now you can find the systematic
defense of pluralism and some detailed
case studies in my book of 2012 which
Rick has kindly mentioned and I'm going
to be publishing further development of
that account in the next few years I
mean just to show you a view of what the
system systematic arguments look like I
argue that there are these kinds of
benefits of tolerating different systems
of knowledge within a field of science
and I argue that there are these
benefits of
interaction but I assume you didn't fly
me out all the way from England to hear
me recite what you can just read in a
book at home with your feet up with a
glass of wine whatever you do when you
read so I'm going to do something
slightly different giving you highlights
of some of the arguments that are
contained in the book and some which are
not in the
book the opposite of pluralism would be
monism and monism is taken as common
sense by most people who appreciate and
defend science according to monism we
should seek the one scientific truth
about the one reality that we all
inhabit together also assuming that
there is one right answer to each given
question and one right method for
arriving at it and perhaps even the
right list of questions to be
asking more prec precisely here's a um
characterization of scientific monism
from actually three of the leading
pluralist uh Steven Keller Helen Lino
and Ken Waters um who called themselves
the Minnesota pluralist because they
were all working at Minnesota Helen Lono
now at Stanford Ken wers in Calgary
leading philosophers of science um they
put it this way monism says that one the
the ultimate aim of a science is to
establish a single complete and
comprehensive account of the natural
world or at least the part of the world
investigated by that science based on a
single set of fundamental
principles monism also maintains that
the nature of the world is such that it
can at least in principle be completely
described or explained by such an
account and there exist in
principle method or methods of inquiry
that if correctly pursued will yield
such an account and I think this is
pretty much Common Sense among many
scientists many people who cherish and
defend science in public as well as
philosophers of science here's a
striking example of the monus dream by
physicist Steven Weinberg right I mean
one of the leading uh uh pioneers of
the road contributions towards the grand
unified theory of elementary particle
physics he wrote in his book dreams of a
final theory in
1992 the century now coming to a close
has seen in physics a dazzling expansion
of the frontiers of scientific knowledge
often we have felt as this Zig freed
after he tasted the dragon's blood when
he found to his surprise that he could
understand the language of birds I
thought that was for orthologist but
this is uh Vagner right uh but now we
are
stuck because this was the time when
when Congress was debating whether to
continue funding the super conducting
super collider project which they did
cancel shortly afterwards Weinberg was
pushing for more money right we're Stu
give us more money we can do it our
present theory is it says that of only
limited validity still tenative and
incomplete but behind them now and then
we catch glimpses of a final Theory one
that would be of unlimited validity and
entirely satisfying in its completeness
and
consistency It's a grand dream indeed
it's the kind of dream I personally had
when I was a teenager which pushed me
into theoretical physics and SC Tech and
I quickly found out um this wasn't what
the day-to-day life of a physics student
involved and
uh I did carry on with some more physics
but I won't tell you my autobiography
now this is just a striking statement of
the monist dream and when we look more
closely we can see two quite distinct
ways in which monism manifest in science
first is this idea of the entire Unity
of science most conceived through
reductionism so here's Ernest ruford
some of you will have recognized his
face he is alleged to have said at one
point all science is either really
physics or is just stamp
collecting and this is you know not not
a rare attitude among fundamental
physicists as punishment for insulting
everybody like this they gave him a
Nobel Prize in chemistry
that was for the transmutation of
elements so you can see why chemists so
excited about
that here's theak the great theoretical
physicist who said in 1929 shortly after
the arrival of shreder Heisenberg
himself doing the standard form of
quantum mechanics as we know it now he
said the underlying physical law is
necessary for the mathematical theory of
a large part of physics and the whole of
chemistry are thus completely
known and now we just have to solve some
very complicated equations which was of
course beneath the genius is like him uh
so now we're still struggling with
computational quantum chemistry but in
1929 he yeah he's all done basically in
principle here's a cartoon that my under
graduate students gave me
once it's uh you can see what's going on
I I'm not going to give you the blow by
blow is the psychologist bullying the
sociologist ah you guys only doing apply
psychology the biologist holding the
octopus saying psychology is just
Applied Biology which is just applied
chemistry which is just applied physics
he hey right so it's all just physics
and everything else right will be taken
care of this is Rutherford's dream uh
expressed in a comic way and actually
the whole cartoon also has the
mathematician over there oh we didn't
see you
guys but it's not just cartoons it's not
just
um scientists speaking of the cuff this
is an example of two very serious
philosophers of science right classic
article by uh Hillary putam and Paul
oppenheim 1958 where they give you that
exactly that picture which was given in
the cartoon right they said all of
science will
be understandable eventually in terms of
Elementary particles because you know
they give you the six levels of
existence in the universe and you know
stuff in level six is made up of stuff
in level five and so on so if we want
start by understanding how Elementary
particles interact with each other and
work stepwise upward we will have the
entirety of science so that's one mode
of monism in which you say all science
is one and it is based most likely in
physics this is the other kind of monism
which exists within each scientific
field and here what we have is um The
Firm belief by the scientific
practitioners and again others as well
that within each field there is basic
the right way to think and the right way
to investigate things the right
fundamental beliefs to have and if
you don't adhere to those fundamental
tenants of each science then you'll be
quickly written off as a credible person
you won't be able to publish anything
you won't be able to get a job and so
and so on so for example right what
biologists would go against the idea of
evolution by random mutation and natural
selection today what physicist would
there propose a theory in which things
can travel faster than spe the speed of
light or have a any account of nature in
which energy is not conserved right and
there are many instances in which this
comes to the surface that's a picture a
blurry picture of um British physicist
Jim alal is also a big TV personality
over in England so he's on TV alot and
this is him on live TV declaring that if
the uh report that had come out uh at
the time several years ago that uh there
were some neutrinos observed to be
traveling fasted in the light alal said
if those reports would be confirmed he
would eat his shorts meaning underwear
which is holding up there um that's his
boxer shorts on live TV
and it's not because alal was
particularly knowledgeable about the
setting of that experiment that these
Italian physicist were reporting or
because he was a particular specialist
on
neutrinos it's just him as a good normal
scientist declaring that this thing
they're claiming is just impossible and
we know it
right and you know we we know from uh
Thomas for example in philosophy of
science history of science that uh in
what Kon called the normal state of
science normal science The Authority
enjoyed by the Paradigm in each field is
an an unchallenged Monopoly right the
Paradigm tells you what the basic
metaphysics of the world the corner of
the world that field deals with is
the Paradigm tells you what
methodologies to use and if you go
against those dictates of the Paradigm
then you cease to be a normal scientist
scientist now for Kon himself he
wouldn't have said that uh this kind of
monism in normal science was justified
because the Paradigm at the time was
necessarily correct but he implied that
the scientists involved in it themselves
would be thinking that for right um
there were many different kinds of
benefits of noral science the most
important of which was that the
narrowing of focus that the Paradigm
allowed enabled actually right the
normal scientist to do esoteric
specialist
research and one of the things going on
there is that the Paradigm allows the
scientist to this regard foundational
questions which you could argue about
until the cows come home and which we
philosophers do argue
about entire lives right uh so
scientists won't get any science done if
they're engaged in in that
business so there are
um strong motivations I think that many
people
have to sign up to a monist view of
Science and here I'm trying to be
slightly uh more systematic I'm
identifying four different
motivations for people to hold the
monist ideal of science uh so there's
the metaphysical idea that because there
is just one world there has to be only
one truth and of course it would be the
should be the job of science to go and
look for that truth there's also a sort
of historical argument based on the
track record of science uh people
believe that uh there have been great
successes in science uh based on these
moves of unification and reduction and
these moves Point towards the ultimate
truth that moist uh presume there to be
just to give you two quick examples I
mean we we always hear about the great
success of Maxwell's electrodynamics
which Unified electricity magnetism and
Optics which had been considered quite
separate Sciences until then all
encapsulated in those four equations
that we still use and put on T-shirts
and so on Maxwell didn't put them in
those terms but never mind that that's
just History of Science um the story of
molecular genetics we also hear about
how what great advances we made by
assuming this one specific specific um
mode of working in biology which also
happens to be a reductionist one so
we're doubly
happy and then there are some more
practical considerations
right so uh when we need to take action
in Practical life for example um what do
we do about climate change we need to
have a scientific consensus so that we
can pull together and carry out some ACT
uh effective
actions and in a similar way you might
feel that there is Need for unified
front against these forces of unreason
and untruth and I don't know if you're
going on the March for science in a few
days you might be feeling this last
bullet point very strongly in your heart
the Practical concerns are indeed very
urgent in the here and now when the
greatest political powers on the planet
seem to be bent on a demotion and
destruction of scientific
truth it's tempting to opt for strong
monism in the face of such threats which
are not entirely new wouldn't it be nice
if we could just declare the scientific
truth and shut down all the nonsense
that's contrary to the truth whether it
be creationism and intelligent design or
climate change denial or the agnotology
practiced by tobacco
companies but I'm going to argue that we
need to resist this temptation this wish
that science would play the role of the
philosopher king or God to tell us what
is true and how we should
live so in the rest of my presentation
today I'll try to talk you out of these
monist motivations I'm going to go
through them one by
one now in response to the idea that
there must be one truth because there is
only one world I would stress the
inaccessibility and inoperability of
such a notion of Truth now this is a
huge philosophical subject which I am
currently working on so I'm not going to
say much about it today unless you want
me to go into it in the discussion
period afterwards I'm just going to
leave you for now with a joke that makes
the point so it's the joke is a brief
dialogue between a student and a teacher
teacher says your composition on my dog
is exactly the same as your sister's did
you copy hers and the student gets very
indignant no sir it's the same
dog that at least should make you think
about the notion that because there's
one world there can only be one good
account of
it what about the idea that the
historical track record of science shows
the effectiveness of monism I'm going to
spend some time on that one the common
image of scientific progress we have I
argue are full of monist
distortions let me talk you through one
important example showing how history is
often dressed up to make it look like
the Right theory always triumphs because
it is right and there's only one best
theory at any given time and that best
theory is inevitably what leads us in
the direction of the ultimate truth I
mean that's the sort of thing that gets
reinforced when we hear about the
history of science whether it be in the
popular media or in the introductory
chapters of science textbooks or or even
sometimes from professional historians
of science so the case I'm going to try
to talk you briefly through is the case
of the chemical revolution of the late
18th century featuring the discovery of
oxygen and the demise of the notorious
fistan Theory the details of this case
um are presented in the first chapter of
my book but I'm just going to give you
some quick highlights here now here's a
typical view of of what happened in the
so-call chemical Revolution with antoan
laier as the Great
Hero it's the kind of thing pauchi can
tell you all about after I leave if you
want to know more so here's an entry in
a fairly respectable Source the arenson
dictionary of scientific biography which
uh so the entry there on laia it says
his is a French chemist universally
regarded as the founder of modern
chemistry whenever you read universally
you should be
suspicious it just means I think but in
this case um it's almost true right
there not many people who would deny
that laier was a great uh one of the
founders of modern chemistry it
continues his contribution to the
science of chemistry were wide ranging
but perhaps his most significant
achievement was his discrediting and
disproof of the fistan theory of
combustion which for so long had been a
stumbling block to a true understanding
of chemistry for those of you who don't
know what fiston is it was this presumed
substance contained in combustible
substances and when the combustible
substance burnt the heat and light
coming out of it was they said fistan
escaping that's the initial idea and you
know as I have argued in print it gets a
lot more sophisticated than that as it
develops and and it was a worthy
opponent of the theory that L was
proposing but I'm not going to tell you
all of that I'm just going to give you a
few moments of irony
actually so here uh is a list I quickly
pulled out three of Love's very top
contributions major innovation ations
right to the science of chemistry first
he Advanced a new theory of
acids According to which he said all
acids contain oxygen and oxygen is what
makes an acid acidic this is some of you
may know right this is why he called the
thing oxygen it's a made a made up word
from Greek Roots meaning the generator
of acids he was so proud of his acidity
theory he called the thing oxygen
Germans still call this zour stuff
right and it's very obvious when you say
it in German I don't know how you guys
can live with this in English we say
oxygen because we don't have any idea
what it
means the second item was the caloric
theory of heat laier said that heat
consisted in a material substance that
flows in and out of things
which we've of course rejected now but
he was very serious about it this is
lao's table of chemical elements on at
the top of which is lumere light caloric
caloric and then oxygen nitrogen
hydrogen the very first chapter of his
new textbook of chemistry was about
caloric and what it
does not something that that he
accidentally just walked into that we
can disregard as not an essential part
of his chemistry and third of course his
new theory of combustion but I mean this
is something we don't usually ask so we
say yeah yeah laier t all of us that
combustion is combination with
oxygen what does combination with oxygen
have to do with light and heat coming
out now we have the story in modern
times about energy levels and how right
potential energy is manifested in terms
of heat and light energy but laia didn't
have that story this is 70 years before
energy conservation so what did he have
he had this theory
that combustion generated heat because
it was the combination of a combustible
substance not with just any kind of
oxygen but with oxygen gas and oxygen
gas according to him was a combination
of what he called oxygen base and lots
of
caloric and when oxygen gas made a
combustible substance the oxygen base
had a higher affinity for the
combustible substance like charcoal than
it did to to caloric so it went and
divorced caloric married the charcoal
and the caloric was released in the free
and perceptible form so laier only got
rid of this fistan idea by inven Ing and
enthusiastically buying into this idea
of caloric just like fistan a weightless
substance sticking like a sore thumb in
his whole system of chemistry based on
this obsession with tracking things by
their weights long story
right and already uh in by
1802 this was in a standard textbook of
chemistry all kinds of problems with
that
La theory of combustion none of which is
about caloric being non-existent but
this is about the internal logic of the
theory for example gunpowder Burns
really well even in the absence of
oxygen in a gas
form it contains oxygen within itself
but not in the gas form so that doesn't
work out inconveniently laier was was
the superintendent of the Paris Arsenal
in in charge of G powder so he and his
his close colleague Berto had a very
interesting argument about how gun
powder would work out but don't let me
get into the details because then you
will be here forever so let me move
on now when I tell you stories like
fistan and oxygen and all
that you may think you know that's just
chemistry and his old
chemistry uh this is not the serious
kind of science we should be looking to
as our ideal so you know if there are
those of you in the room who suffer from
physics Envy
um let's talk about some Physics right
and the main thing I'm going to try to
tell you is that even physics isn't like
physics even physics isn't like the way
the monist Imagine physics to be and and
there are a few different points here
which I'll try to go through quite
quickly in the interest of time
now something that really um feeds the
monist enthusiasm about physics is the
idea that um in physics we have these
theories of universal
applicability right starting with things
like Newton's universal law of
gravitation so it's a very con venient
basis to build monist science on right
it wouldn't work as nicely if you had a
law of nature that worked within only
certain confines and broke down outside
Newton came up with his laws of motion
and gravitational law which had
Universal validity and since then we've
been led to believe that all fundamental
laws theories of physics are like that
but it really is just a presumption I
mean it was for Newton himself he knew
that himself very well right because all
the data he had were from at best within
the solar system and he says Ah and I
think that applies
everywhere and he knew he was
uncomfortable with it which is why he
put up this so-called rule of reasoning
in philosophy meaning natural philosophy
which said one should generalize unless
there are specific reasons for not doing
so so we say yes general relativity and
quantum mechanics these theories apply
everywhere therefore whatever macro
physics that we might
have has to be reducible to one of these
theories or their descendants that are
even more General
right now why do we think that I don't
want to go deeply into general
relativity here but let me remind you
that when general relativity was
accepted it was on the basis of three
specific tests right bending of light
red shift and the peran shift of mercury
three very very specific test on the
basis of which somehow the physicist
decare that this Theory applies it to
the entire history of the universe
everywhere and I don't get
that let's think about quantum mechanics
I mean before we really get excited
about Shing our cat and everything let's
why don't we make sure that quantum
mechanics does apply to
cats why are we so sure about
this and there are in fact some
physicists who are seriously making
empirical investigations of this right
LED for example by Anton Zinger in
Vienna uh they are trying to see what
size molecules they can use to show the
quantum interference effects so their
view is yeah there there is a limit to
the applicability of quantum mechanics
and we're going to experimentally find
out where the boundary is rather than
just
assuming it just applies universally
because it has to
right so you know I think we need to add
ask where do we actually use these
theories fundamental theories and where
do we need other theories so for example
in solid state physics which I'll come
to more if there's
time in order to explain things like
super conductivity and super fluidity
they discovered realized that they had
to have Concepts at that level which
weren't apparently reducible to concepts
of elementary particle physics here's
another great
irony I mean most of you will have
suffered through this whatever your
field of study when we teach physics to
students
today why do we make everybody suffer
through newtonium mechanics
first because we then tell that it's all
wrong and here are better theories but
why do we have to teach them the wrong
Theory first why not just get rid of it
like we don't teach Aristotelian physics
in year one right but we have to start
with Newton that's because newtonia
mechanics is still extremely
useful I mean what is rocket science for
the most part is newtonium
mechanics we don't fly Rockets with
general relativity we might make some
specific corrections to the Newtonian
picture using general relativity but
that's not the we can't do the whole
thing with general relativity certainly
not with quantum
mechanics so Newtonian physics is
clearly very useful and that's why we
keep it that's why we teach it and
that's why we keep using it and this uh
is a prime example of some uh part of my
Doctrine which I called the
conservationist uh sideo pluralism right
this system worked very well during
Newton's time
in the domain where he was applying it
to and it still works really well in
those domains nature hasn't changed that
much right so why not keep that system
that works still very well and we do
this is the practice of physics teaching
and physics research and physics
application we do use newtonium
mechanics we don't throw it
away and the deeper reasons why we keep
newtonium mechanics as well well which I
just mentioned right this is the time
independent shredding equation for one
particle some of you know this some of
you don't even if you don't all you need
to notice here is the Little M that is
mass what is mass in quantum
mechanics the meaning of mass came from
neonian mechanics and it remains there
until you get something like the whole
story with the higs Bon which shreder
certainly had no conception of so he was
just using the classical concept of mass
similarly with what you have to plug
into here to the potential function
which is just a Kum potential in case of
Elementary um ordinary quantum
mechanics there's some other issues too
which I won't go into in detail right
now so to sum up this
point the second one um I would say that
our image of the inex success of monist
science is really an illusion only
maintained by a carefully orchestrated
selective
attention my old teacher John dpre once
wrote that reductionism is not a tide
sweeping through all of science it just
is something that happen to be
successful in some specific
situations now now let me come to the
third point
there so that's the desirability of a
unified theory for Effective
action here I want to take a realistic
view of science I don't mean the realist
view of science soall is actually kind
of the opposite of
that so yes if we had an
impeccably um true unified theory that
did everything we needed that would be
great but we don't we hardly ever have
such a theory I mean it was great while
the Heyday of newtonium mechanics lasted
seemed to do a lot of things with a
promise to do a lot more quickly enough
scientists found out there were very
clear limits to the applicability of
neonian
physics so what do we do in real life
situations where most likely we don't
have a unified theory that does
everything we want what we need to do is
learn to make inquiries and take actions
on the basis of the disunified knowledge
that we've got and if we take an honest
look at the history of science we do
find many cases in which Science and
Technology made great progress in a
pluralist
manner one example which I'm not going
to go through today is uh atomic
molecular chemistry in the 19th century
this is the subject of Chapter 3 of my
book um where I argue that there are at
as at least five different systems of
atomic molecular chemistry flourishing
uh throughout the 19th century and this
pluralistic situation did a lot of
good I am going to tell you a little bit
about uh my current research current
historical research which is about
batteries in the 19th century now that
might strike you as kind of weird who
cares about
batteries uh well I make it my business
to pick up the simplest things in
science like water being H2O and how to
make thermometers and show actually how
complicated they are so batteries are
another one and and much worse than the
other things I've seen before so here's
um a renowned historian of physics Helia
crra in Denmark who wrote in
2000 uh what makes the Volta controversy
both interesting and unusual is its long
duration and complex structure the Volta
controversy meaning when Volta invented
the so-called Pile in the year
1799 how did it
work and it was very controversial so
Crow continues none of the great
theoretical breakthroughs of the 19
Century had a decisive influence on the
controversy in a modified form it was
revived in the
1880s although in a social sense the
controversy had largely disappeared by
1910 there was no consensus on the
question of whether or not contact
potentials exist as an intrinsic
property of
metals so this may sound very strange to
you but that's how it was the entire
19th century they argued about how
batteries work
and couldn't agree yet to to anticipate
the conclusion of this brief Glimpse at
this long
project still great Science and
Technology happened through this
pluralist mess a very quick view of what
the argument was about so there's volter
and his original picture of the pile
which um in a little section looks like
this silver plate on top of which a zinc
plate and a wet piece of paper clothing
cardboard anything wettable for Volta
originally it was just soaked in salt
water and then repeat pile it up to
increase the accumulation of voltage and
volta's view was that what generated the
flow of the electrical fluid as he put
it is this balic contact silver and
zinc come together and the electrical
fluid wanted to go to the silver
right in contrast many more people
subscribed to the so-called chemical
Theory and there the way they built the
pile was actually different right so in
contrast to this they said no the cell
is a a sandwich of two metals with the
wet stuff in the middle and the
generator of electricity was the
chemical reaction between the wet stuff
and one of the metals in this case zinc
right so
arguments really uh carried on about the
conflict between contact and chemical
Theory and I mean the main stream was
going into the chemical side but there
are really weird curious things uh on
the side of the contact Theory so there
are so-called dry piles for example a
voltaic pile made with not wet layers
but dry layers in between and they don't
generate much current but they do
generate voltage and this is a very bad
picture of one that they have at the
physics department in Oxford which has
apparently been working for over a 100
years because there's such little action
it can go on forever even more
intriguingly the discovery of the uh
thermal couple by zc in 1821 is just a
loop of two different Metals one here
one there and you put the two Junctions
at different temperatures and suddenly
electric current starts flowing right
this was actually the form of the
battery used by gorg om in the
experiments that established 's law
where is the chemical action in that so
that was a very interesting question and
if you ask today's chemistry teachers
how does a battery work they'll give you
this picture
right nice this is the Daniel
configuration in which they actually two
electrolytes one metal dipped in its own
solution the other metal dipped in its
own solution the two electrolytes
communicate through a porous barrier so
uh ionic Uh current is allowed through
it and you just take the Redux potential
on each side and the difference between
the Redux potentials is the cell voltage
very easy but voltage configuration
wasn't like that nor is your dur cell
right the standard commercial batteries
right the classic one being the carbon
zinc battery so I found only one
chemistry textbook which tells you about
this I mean the university level and
it's this really interesting book called
The extraordinary chemistry of ordinary
things by Carl Snider it's a first year
university level book he says although
the carbon zinc batter is one of our
simpler consumer products the chemistry
that goes on inside that wet black paste
is much too complex to be described in
detail here so he didn't do it and I
haven't found another book that does
it think about if you know some
chemistry think about why that should
produce 1.5 Vol it's not
trivial now so that's the um story of
batteries which I'm currently
investigating it'll be a whole book so
so I can't tell you um all the details
but again the point is that um there
were many different views and many
different experimental Traditions that
flourished in this field of science and
technology
right and also disputes concerning the
very nature of electricity continued
throughout the 19th century it's only at
the very end of the century that
electrons are discovered right so all
the profusion of different system
systems of what I'm calling battery
science were done without electrons yet
great and Lasting scientific and
technological achievements were made on
that basis everything from the telegraph
to Maxwell and electrodynamics achieved
on the basis of these batteries and the
effects that they
produced again you might say that such
examples only illustrate how things were
in the infancy of Science and Technology
but the same kind of things happen today
too I'm just going to give you one
example of Cutting Edge modern science
which is the global positioning system
GPS surely one of the most impressive
and useful scientific Technologies of
the 21st century which most of us carry
with us on a daily I mean all the time
right I don't because this is my phone
but
most of you probably do this is an
example I picked up from a brief mention
by Peter Gallison and I thought about it
and it was a fantastic case illustrating
the virtues of pluralism so this is a
prime example of how you can bring
different systems together in order to
produce something that each of the
systems by itself couldn't possibly do
so how does GPS work some of you know
this very well better than and I do if
you don't here's the basic idea you fly
a whole bunch of geostatic right
satellites which maintain their their
position relative to spots on the
surface of the Earth and then to locate
each spot on the surface of the Earth
you fire um radiation signals uh from
several satellites each one tracking how
long it takes for the signal to come and
go and come back and from there you can
basically triangulate the position of
the spot you want to know about how do
we do this well we have to use newtonium
mechanics as I mentioned before to fly
the
satellites then you have to put atomic
clocks on the satellit because the time
measurements have to be extremely
precise for which you need quantum
mechanics but that's not enough you have
to correct the atomic
clocks using both General relative it
and special relativity special
relativity to account for the slowing
down of the clocks according to the
speed at which they're moved around
general relativity to correct for the
gravitational changing of clock
rates and you have to use blend all
these different physic types of physics
skillfully together operate this system
and the satellite will beam down to you
on Earth the signal which you use
pretending that the Earth is flat so
it's a wonderful blend of uh all kinds
of physics which delivers fantastic
results I'm going to be very brief about
the last Point um
so the last motivation for monism namely
the need for united front against
unreason and un truth I'm just going to
say there's great futility in danger in
fighting dogmatism with
dogmatism okay I think sometimes we have
to do it if it's a matter of defeating
Hitler but you can debate how much you
got out of that if you did it by
subscribing to
stalinism so um I'm just going to leave
it at that if scientists become dogmatic
in order to combat dogmatic
pronouncements by the church or whatever
you got what will we have gained
so I hope I've been able to take
something away from these common
motivations towards monism and the fear
of what would happen to science and our
civilization without
monism but if you if I may go on for a
little bit more I must anticipate some
monist objections because there are a
lot of objections that some of you are
probably thinking and I've always
received when I presented this ideas
there are lots of objections but I'm
just going to focus briefly on two of
them the first is the anxiety that
people feel um in the absence of the
notion of the one truth that we can seek
and rely on they feel that if we don't
have monism we're going to end up with a
relativist chaos in which just anything
goes to quote fire are bent out of
context so the slogan I put out is not
many and not anything goes but many
things go but not just anything right we
survey our situation we choose several
of the best systems that we can afford
to maintain and develop not just
anything that anybody with a loud voice
shouts about so the the example people
always try to hit me with is creationism
right so if you're a pluralist do you
have to allow the teaching of
creationism in schools on an equal basis
with darwinian Evolution no right
because the spirit of pluralism as I'm
advocating is that we we gain scientific
benefits from exploring the best of the
options that we have and if you had to
rank all the different ways of
explaining
life creationism would be like number
632 so you don't want to keep that alive
that's the judgment that I'm making
that's the Judgment that we all have to
make individually and collectively so
you might want to argue about punctuated
equilibrium you might want to argue
about epigenetic inheritance which
people seem to do with Great Gusto in
biology these days you might even
propose to bring back neol
lamaris even the holistic vitalism of
only beung and the like but not
creationism right so that's the first
worry the second one is um the second
objection to pluralism which I often get
is something I already mentioned several
times I mean I I often give historical
examples and people say well that was
then but this is now right there was
immature science and now science has got
good enough so that we can be reasonably
sure about the
basics against that notion there's the
famous argument of the pessimistic
induction from The History of Science
right this is the formulation by status
pillos who himself doesn't subscribe to
it at all but it's a nice summary so the
argument goes the history of science is
full of theories which at different
times and for long periods had been
empirically successful and yet were
shown to be false in the Deep structure
claims they made about the world
therefore the empirical success of a
theory provides no warrant for the claim
that the theory is even approximately
true so you know let's think about the S
track record of science there lots of
things people used to believe in ranging
from fistan to The
Ether and Beyond and we've rejected all
of those now but those people are really
sure on the basis of good reasons too so
how can we be so sure that 200 years
from now they're going to be laughing so
hard at the early 20th century about
dark energy and all that
stuff so let's have a little bit of
humility now py bridan Nobel prize
winning um Harvard
physicist had a really Grim view about
uh our Prospect in science he said if we
sufficiently extend our range we shall
find that nature is intrinsically and
its elements neither understandable nor
subject to
law his main work in science was high
pressure physics increasing the
available pressure attainable pressure
by a hundredfold from his best
predecessors and sure enough he found
things were weird under those extremely
high pressures unpredictably weird like
ice having several different Crystal
structures
now I've already discussed this uh um
kind of point before so I'm just going
to try to give you a little bit more
uplifting Vision in conclusion here's
Joseph Priestley the the tragic
anti-hero of the chemical Revolution who
made oxygen called it def fisticated air
refused to go with LA's
interpretation he said this really
interesting thing that every Discovery
in science brings to our view many
things of which we had no intimation
before the greater is the circle of
light meaning knowledge the greater is
the boundary of the darkness by which
the circle is confined and that boundary
is ignorance right so I made a picture
of
this vast
Darkness knowledge is in this little
circle of light the kind of ignorance
that we can deal with is the boundary
right the the deep dark stuff that's
that's the unknown unknowns of ramsfeld
there's nothing we can do about
that so Priestly pictures the more we
know the more we don't know or we know
we don't know but he was happy about
this and that's the last impression I
want to leave you with he continued not
withstanding this the more light we get
the more thankful we ought to be for by
this means we have the greater range for
satisfactory cont
contemplation in time the bounds of
light will be still farther extended and
from the Infinity of the divine nature
and the Divine works we may promise
ourselves an endless progress in our
investigation of them a prospect truly
Sublime and
glorious now he's saying it this way
because he was a priest very
appropriately named he
was I'm a humanist my general
perspective is
to look at science as a human Enterprise
now I don't mean in the human chauvinist
way I I mean science as something done
by intentional agents like Homo sapiens
but not necessarily that and I think
humanism gives us this basic kind of
humility which is the foundation of the
pluralist point of view I'm trying to
get across here's Clarence Irving Lewis
said to be said said to have been the
last great pragmatist philosopher and he
was reviewing John DWI book and Louis
said channeling DWI Spirit man may not
reach the goal of his quest for security
by any flight to another world neither
to that other world of the religious
Mystic nor to that realm of transcendent
ideas and eternal values which is its
philosophical
counterpart salvation is through work
through experimental effort intell ently
directed to an actual human
future so let me conclude with some
basic epistemic humility it is easy to
recognize that no system of knowledge
and science should be given the right to
suppress exclude and delegitimize all
others because we need as many systems
as we can afford to maintain in order to
give ourselves the maximum exposure to
reality
the knowledge gained by such a pluralist
process can also contribute
appropriately to the full actualization
of the human
potential after many centuries of
struggle and miserable failures we
humans have learned to accept and
benefit from such a spirit of pluralism
in the Realms of politics culture
language Cuisine Art and
ecology I believe it's time to admit it
in science
too now as a coda to this talk I should
explain what this weird picture is which
I also put on the poster advertising
this event is that once a metaphorical
and literal expression of the kind of
pluralism um I'm trying to promote so
first literally is it's a long lost old
experiment that I recovered from the
past so it's from this paper of 1806 by
a guy named Charles
Sylvester now if you've never heard of
this man nobody
has even the professional historians of
Science of this period hardly ever heard
of him he was one of these Great British
amateur scientist of that time writing
in Nicholson's
Journal this paper he
says if a thin coat of a solution of
nitrate of silver be laid upon a piece
of plain glass and in the center of this
be laid a bit of zinc wire in a little
time a beautiful tree of silver will
appear as if growing from The Wire so I
read this I said yeah
sure that's going to happen um so I not
you know I have this kind of experience
a lot reading old science I get weird
reports some of them are just crazy
other are actually true so I thought how
hard is it to check this out so it's a
slight variation I made in his procedure
instead of a glass uh pane I put up a
little plastic envelope the kind you put
photographs in and instead of zinc I
used copper because it comes out
prettier um and there's a just the dark
paper board um the dark green um in the
uh plas envelope just to show the
contrast better and I carefully put in a
little solution of silver nitrate about
one mol works best and immediately this
happens now everybody would expect that
to happen because um copper dissolves
more readily than silver does in nitric
acid so there's an immediate replacement
happening The Alchemist knew about this
no
problem but if you let this sit this
starts happening so the silver is now
growing on the
silver and there's no battery connected
to this is all
self-driving and after 26 minutes this
is what happened that that was
particularly beautiful the the shooting
off of the thin
slivers and different configurations
start to happen that particular one I
was very pleased to watch you could see
it just shoot out in real time so that's
the tree just as uh Sylvester says and
you know it it's a very small thing it's
a little phenomenon um it's not known to
most of the chemists that I talk to
today not because it's that difficult
but because why would you do
this this kind of thing is done
sometimes for demonstration it's usually
done with a battery then it goes a lot
faster but uh it's actually not trivial
to explain why this happens the way it
does and it's just a small example of
how History of Science can recover some
things that are left behind in the
forward March of science especially if
that forward March is done in the
monistic way metaphorically this is a
very fitting image I think of pluralist
science an intriguing reminder of the
fragility in completeness and many sided
abundance of the pluralistic scientific
knowledge that we can develop I spoken
too long I'm sorry about that let me
stop here thank you for
[Applause]
listening great thank you very much um
please join us at a reception following
in the room directly below us uh and
since this is being uh recorded uh we'd
like to get your questions on the
microphone so uh uh any
questions yeah so I was really
interested by the quotes to use at the
start of the talk specifically the wiber
and dur R quotes um and I wondered if if
you thought that of two different things
were going on in the sets of quotes
where with the dur and the you have a
certain kind of aggressive reductionism
the argument is that chemistry and
biology and by implication everything
else reduces to fundamental physics
whereas with Weinberg you're getting a
different sort of claim that all sorts
of forces can theoretically be explained
by recourse to Run unified theory yeah
and it it seems like physicists end up
talking about unified theories or
theories of everything actually fairly
recently like in the 70s ' 80s and '90s
um and I wondered if this particular
brand of monism you're arguing against
in in your talk is something of a recent
development for what it lineage is
exactly yeah thank you that's a very
nice question and I mean just to bring
it
slightly back to the way I initially
framed it the Weinberg quote strictly
speaking is only about Unity within
physics right he's not saying that
having done the
unified theory of physics we can then
take care of chemistry and all the rest
of it but I think it's implied um in in
his thinking I may be wrong about that
but uh he does say that yeah okay in
other places right yeah now to your
question of whether this is a new
phenomenon I don't think it it really is
so um this dream of a universal theory
of physics I mean that does descend from
Newton himself
right the wisdom of Newton was that he
knew what to publish and what not to
publish so all that Alchemy and theology
he did he knew not to publish and we
only knew much later that he had done
all that work but you
know you can get glimpse glimpses of
this for example in the quer is that he
attaches to the Optics he talks about
The Ether right Prim concept of the E
which was supposed to explain all kinds
of things from chemical forces to
electricity um after Newton people uh
get very enamored with the idea of the
so-called subtle or imponderable fluids
right the examples that I mentioned
being caloric and fistan so for example
there there's this great drive towards a
unified theory of imponderable fluids in
which people postulated something they
called Elementary fire uh which had
these different manifestations coloric
fistan light electricity magnetism so
that drive towards a grand unification
certainly has been with us uh at least
intermittently throughout modern science
and I guess some people would trace it
all the way back to Da in ancient Greece
so not entirely knew but I think it did
come up very strongly in elementary
particle physics in the 70s as you
say so um can I just follow up on that
um line of questioning maybe um asking
newness in a slightly different way it
seemed the the part of that quotation
that struck me the lber quotation was
the
funding you know we need the money we're
almost there uhh and it seems like
there's probably a way of connecting
particular Arguments for monism
particular anxieties about the
conditions and possibility for doing
science I'm thinking here in particular
of babage in 29 whose decline of science
argument is in fact an argument about
how his calculating machine should be
funded by the British government French
or funding so I wonder and so science
itself as a whole is declining in this
way but what he really means is please
I'm almost there just give me five more
years of essentially governmental
support I'm wondering if there's a kind
of lineage of the connection between
monism and money that pluralism that
pluralism isn't as convincing right that
somehow these arguments about pluralism
aren't the arguments that are front and
center in the March for Science and
there's a kind of tacit monism in some
of the ways that it's being described
and I wonder if that's because when push
comes to shove for individual scientists
or for scientists as a group monism
seems to cash the checks in a way it
does in fact or not yeah I think you're
right absolutely
um if I may be TR monism certainly is a
great marketing employe right we are
going to give you the
truth who wouldn't fund that
well it's the same kind of sales pitch
that Alchemists used to make right we're
going to give you the secret of matter
and eternal life so please it's
expensive research right and all this
patronage s going on throughout
Medieval Europe
so it does excite people right and
therefore is better for uh seeking
attracting funding and I think it's the
kind of that's part of the picture of
what I think of as the immaturity of
science that we got to get over right
this this
um search for the one One Truth uh
because I think I mean many of the
scientists I talk to tell me that uh the
great stumbling block to a reasonable
kind of pluralism is in the funding
structure right and uh let me just just
something came to my mind that might be
relevant uh this is something that I
read from James Lovelock The Gua guy U
he wrote at the Millennium in a British
newspaper that he thinks that just 1% of
the National Science budget should go to
the crazy
people like himself right he didn't say
crazy people but the Mavericks the
people with unusual ideas the out of the
box thinkers just 1% so that if if it
comes to nothing we won't be that
sorry but some nice things may come of
it right so I think that kind of
thinking is going to be more helpful
than right I'm going to going to tell
you the truth so give me
billions I have a comment regarding that
hypothesis you just presented I think
that the necessity of simplifying a
theory into a simpler formulation where
you have a smaller number of principles
m is um is a wonderful uh Direction that
Mak science first of all simpler yeah
and also easier to implement and to
think about if one has a theory for each
rock that falls there is a different
gravitational Theory or you have one
theory that simplifies the description
of all rocks I all by a single um
expression I think a single theory that
makes a theory a lot more powerful and
makes understanding of the world much
more easier so regardless of funding and
regardless of um any other goal
simplification of science is the minimum
number of principles is highly desirable
and so uh when pluralism um is is useful
because there is no way of simplifying
it then in science it is maintained and
celebrated and so it is only reduced
when it is found that one of those
principles that was thought to be
necessary is not necessary so that's
that's the way science science works you
you reduce the number of principles the
simple possible theory Sure and what
Weinberg is saying here is that there is
the possibility of making science as
simple as it is imp possibly conceivable
and they're close to achieving that goal
so that is um
basically an approach
to uh to science that has been pursued
for many many years
and is makes science more powerful and
and SAR thank you I certainly agree with
that um but I think there is a
distinction to be made between
Simplicity and
Monopoly right I don't think so so you
don't think so science there's no
supression so your question was long
enough
sir that your question was long
enough I mean
think about the GPS case right if you
try to make the theory of GPS it would
be enormously complicated so instead
what we do we have Newtonian mechanics
which is pretty simple we have quantum
mechanics itself as simple as can be in
exactly the way you propose uh likewise
for relativity and then we learn to pull
those things together at this point of
application right so in in other words
this desire to keep scientific theor
simple may also end up with a
pluralistic result right because if the
world is a complicated beast and you
want simple theories the best you can
have is various theories which simply
expresses various aspects of that
complex nature
right now if weinberg's dream would come
true in which we have one simple Theory
that does everything yeah sure even I
might take it but I would want to make
another
one it seems to me there might be a
constraint on pluralism which is that
you have to write as clearly as leazier
wrote and tell people as clearly how to
do what you're doing so that they can
test it out as well yes yes I mean one
as one aspect of the whole thing that I
didn't go into today is communication
right because in my ideal picture of
pluralism it's not just a matter of
having different competing Traditions
that don't talk to each other right it's
also the higher form of pluralism is the
interactive one and how do we make
communication between let's say
incommensurable paradigms possible and
we have to work pretty hard at that
right um Peter gison talks about this uh
he says in fact within modern physics
itself there are three different
subcommunities right the experimentalist
the theoreticians and the
instrumentation people uh and they are
really different communities they don't
speak the same language but they have to
come together to do the great
experimental work as going going on at
CERN and other places so how do they do
it he thinks they have to in effect make
up on the spot almost pigeon languages
right the these uh hybrid languages
through which they can do communicate
well enough and I think we we have to
think about a lot of these things and
the clarity of communication as you
mentioned is a key
thing I think it's a great pity that
love was with that gift of clarity used
it to suppress the opposition rather
than trying to communicate with
it one last
question so unfortunately I think my
question is going to be following up on
a lot of these reduction questions uh I
think that we've heard a lot of
approaches historically of why
reductionism might be so attractive to
mods um
I'm interested
why you could say philosophically as
opposed to psychologically yeah
reductionism is so powerful you made
this off theand comment I think you said
from your teacher your former teacher
that uh
reductionism isn't a tithe it just has
been at certain moments yeah well have
those certain moments just been so
conducive in the history of science that
or so coincidental that they overtaken
our thinking about uh monism or is there
something I know plenty of philosophers
have written about about why it's so
influential but as you're a pluralist
why might you think that reductionism is
so philosophically attrac that's a great
question I used to think that is that
these moments like maxwellian
unification of electricity magnetism and
light were so impressive and memorable
likewise weinberg's
achievements but now I think there's a
deeper layer of the story uh which is
metaphysical I can't go into all of that
now but the gist of it is that we seem
to have uh some deep underlying
assumptions we a lot of us that stuff
can be smashed up into Elementary
particles and everything is made up from
elementary particles in the way that we
put Lego blocks together to make things
so you know philosophers will
metaphysicians will talk about the
myology of right substances and objects
and I think that is actually a very
interesting illusion right
because modern physics has shown us that
Elementary particles don't STI stick
together like Lego blocks do right I
mean they're extreme cases like pair
creation and Annihilation right so
electron and vron come together and
disappear into gamma rays are we going
to say that the gamma rays are composed
of an electron and a positron and vice
versa well you can but not in the sense
of Lego blocks right in nuclear
reactions energy is always lost and
gained or
gained and
that means we haven't exactly just put
together two neutrons or proton and a
neutron or whatever you've got to make
the bigger
lump energy is matter and vice versa and
you know you might say well it's just a
small fractional loss of mass going on
in these reactions but if we did that
that then then we wouldn't be able to
explain nuclear bombs and that's not a
good science if you have to you know
approximate away nuclear
explosions so I think uh this deep
underlying assumption that many
philosophers have that physical
composition is miror logical is is at
the heart of this um Drive pulled into
um reductionism in the metaphysical
sense and once you've granted metaphys
physical reductionism it's really an
uphill battle to say still we don't give
you
epistemological reductionism I mean
people do it but it's hard work so I
think there is that deeper
layer well let's thank speaker V thank
you
[Music]